on prime crime
a grisly death i don't know of any case
that actually
viscerally impacted me more that leads
into a tough case
this could be an accident and the
shocking moments
caught on tape
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases now it's
no surprise that tragedies occur every
day
but how do we know if something is
really an accident
or murder there's a baby on the ground
june 18 2014 vinings georgia
people at a shopping center watch in
horror as a man
pulls out a toddler's body from an suv
we don't know if the baby is breathing
it's realizing it looks like
this do you see anybody around him yeah
his dad and it looks like somebody's
gonna give him cpr
the boy is 22 month old cooper harris
and the father is 33 year old justin
ross harris
a web developer for home depot we would
learn that the child was left inside of
that suv
for approximately seven hours on an
incredibly hot
summer day
a witness would later recount how harris
said i left him in the car
in fact it's reported that harris
initially tried to perform cpr on his
son
but then gave up and walked away
you would think that this would go to
you know this kind of
parental primal response where you want
to do everything to breathe
life into this precious child he was not
doing it and
it the last hands to touch this child
were the hands of strangers
when police arrive things get even more
tense
harris apparently gets into a
confrontation with the officers
[Music]
as for cooper he would ultimately be
pronounced dead
a vehicle and temperature
were literally weaponized you have him
in a restrained position in this car
seat
where he cannot move
the exterior temperature got all the way
up to 92 degrees fahrenheit
now you're inside of this metal bubble
increase that by about 30 degrees that's
the same
heat level that we will turn an oven on
at home
and you have the onset of what
essentially is hyperthermia
and that is an increased body
temperature now he's got tremendous
anxiety he's shallow breathing
and now he's inhalating hot air
he finally had a fatal seizure his heart
literally stopped
this child suffered just suffered like
none of us can even begin to imagine
how could this happen harris is brought
into police headquarters
he says this is all a mistake
harris explains to investigators how the
day unfolded
but listen carefully to what happened
next
is it possible a father just forgot
about his baby son in the back seat
this could be an accident and in fact
there was a case in texas
in which it was very publicized it was
prior to this case and it was determined
in that case that there was no evidence
that it was anything
other than an accident
[Music]
i couldn't compose myself and do it
he had that there in his face
i knew that i had done what every parent
and then my fears they've done and that
just
legal stuff
this just doesn't make sense to me
that someone could forget this
precious little angel that you had just
eaten breakfast with within two miles of
your final destination
and you park your car
and you leave it struck me you know who
am i to judge
anyone relative to their parenting
skills but there is a certain awareness
that comes along with parenting
particularly at this age 18 months old
they're completely
defenseless in this world and and are
very very fragile
what you're hearing is just the start of
justin ross harris's interview
up next there's so much more
[Music]
it's june 18 2014 in georgia
and justin ross harris is explaining to
law enforcement
how he accidentally left his 22 month
old son
cooper in his car for hours on a hot day
an act that resulted in cooper's death
is this a tragic mistake or
something else at first harris appears
devastated
i think that there is an argument that
he does
seem genuinely honest
oh
[Music]
this is a small vehicle and the
positioning of the car seat
relative to where cooper was
was immediately over the driver's right
shoulder
even when you disembark from the vehicle
he's still going to be in eyesight
however there are strange turns in this
interview
like when harris starts cracking jokes
[Music]
or when he gets defensive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
at one point harris's wife leanna comes
in to speak with her husband
it's when the two are talking seemingly
without knowing they're being recorded
that things get weirder
[Music]
who would say that it struck me as an
odd thing to say to your husband
who you've created life with and that
now that life is
gone what it's rather cryptic
isn't it
it's not that everybody reacts the same
but it is not typical behavior one might
expect
to see out of someone who's lost their
son in this manner
one of the most controversial statements
during that interview
is when justin ross harris said this
[Music]
who wouldn't want their 22 month old
son back anybody would that doesn't make
sense
if this was such an accidental event
why would you attempt to console those
and i think
sell those in the room on this idea that
the child is now
at peace it's a very i think short trip
uh intellectually now we're starting to
wonder
did harris intend to kill cooper
when we return there's more to this
georgia father
than meets the eye
[Music]
your actions causes
how is that against them georgia father
justin ross harris
is sitting in a police interrogation
room back in 2014.
he's trying to explain to authorities
that he mistakenly killed his 22 month
old son cooper
by inadvertently leaving him in the back
seat of a car for hours on a summer day
a terrible tragedy that has happened to
many families in the past
during his interview there are times
when harris seems distraught
however there's some additional evidence
to consider
first let's go back to harris's day
they lunchtime and picked me up um
we went to publix at lunch they took me
back
and dropped me off while harris talked
about going to lunch
what he didn't tell police was that he
also purchased light bulbs
and after lunch placed them on the front
seat
a moment captured by surveillance video
keep in mind at this time cooper is in
the car still
he doesn't notice that a child's in his
car seat
his child's in his car seat but there's
some
argument too of how the appearance of
the child would have been at that point
whether or not in a hot car there would
have been a smell that there likely
would have been
that could have alerted him to the fact
something was amiss inside his car
the fact that he didn't mention that
when he was first
questioned by police could he have
forgotten could you argue that he was
stressed out and he forgot that he'd
done that that he couldn't think
clearly absolutely but i think those two
events together
again raised suspicion
that he really knew he'd done it
then there's leanna harris's wife
while on the surface harris comes off as
a devoted family man a search of his
phone and internet history
reveals a disturbing secret harris
had been having multiple affairs
including encounters with both women
and men he had sex with prostitutes
messaged people using whisper and had
even sexted
with underage girls he was actively
seeking out these relationships
in locations that were not immediately
around where he was domiciled he
allegedly had driven all the way from
atlanta
to tuscaloosa which is quite a distance
down i-20 in order to
cruise for young
co-eds and that's not all on the day of
cooper's death
he was messaging women sending sexually
graphic pictures
and wrote online just minutes before
leaving his toddler in the car
i love my son and all but we both need
escapes
and i hate being married with kids the
novelty
has worn off he didn't want
his 22 month old he wanted to have all
these other extracurricular activities
that was his focus that was his time not
parenting
that is at least the approach the
prosecution took
with establishing motive in this case
there was actually one
search that was discovered on the
perpetrator's search engine
he had been looking at hot car deaths
and of course defense tried to say
this was related to the deaths of
animals and cars and i'm thinking
and is that is that all you got
that shows forethought that shows
planning
and that again is just absolutely
insidious
out of all the modalities the one you're
going to choose
is death by hot car and that is just
chilling to the bone justin ross harris
is eventually charged with both
malice and felony murder as well as
child cruelty
in connection with cooper's death he
also was indicted on multiple sex crimes
charges
related to messaging minors
up next does the state have enough to
convict harris
or is this not what it seems
ross has always acknowledged that this
was his fault
what you're going to see during this
trial is that responsible
isn't the same thing as criminal
stay with us
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father
guilty or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before get caught
in providence
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is law and
crime
2016 was the start of the trial of
justin ross harris
a georgia father facing murder and sex
crimes charges
the prosecution argued that harris
intentionally killed his 22 month old
son cooper
by leaving him in a hot car to die in
order to live a child-free lifestyle
as evidenced by extramarital affairs and
communications with underage girls
the defense though said their client was
innocent
cooper's death was an accident it was
always
an accident the defense even called
harris's now
ex-wife lyanna to support their case
ross loved this little boy yes he did
yeah
yet the prosecution was armed with a lot
of evidence
from proof that harris knew cooper was
in the car
to the defendant's arguably bizarre
interrogation tape
[Music]
oh
and the state had the advantage of
calling the women who harris had been
sexting during his marriage
how old were y'all when he met was 18
how old was do he have a wife
yes do you have a kid yes but he loved
you and y'all were best friends
yes
um did he seem nervous or anything i
don't
we talk about like everyday things and
they get
sexual so much okay and we're pictures
sent back and forth
okay these are different parts of your
body private parts
after hearing all the evidence the jury
had to decide if cooper's death was an
accident
or murder it took them four days to
deliberate
but the jury ultimately came back with
their verdict
justin ross harris was convicted across
the board of
all charges when i look through that
lens and look back at interviews and
conversations
my frustration is his i feel like he was
trying to
cover up what he did or he was trying to
emote in ways that he would be
believable
[Music]
what factually was a horrendous horrific
experience for this 22 month old
child who had been placed in the trust
of his father
and in violation and dereliction of
duty to that child if not love of that
child
callously walked away and left that
child in a hot car
in june in georgia
in the summer to swelter and die
sentence of the court is life to serve
in confinement
without parole in addition to life in
prison
justin ross harris was also sentenced to
an additional consecutive term of 32
years
on the other charges despite harris's
fight on appeal
at the time of this recording the court
has denied him
a new trial some of the grounds were
specific to things the judge hadn't
hadn't allowed as evidence and the
opportunity for the defense to
cross-examine
i'm not surprised that it was denied the
court's going to say you've already had
your bite at the apple
nothing was done that was erroneous and
so you don't get a second bite
by all accounts harris will spend the
remainder of his days
locked away thinking about what he did
to his son i don't know of any case that
actually viscerally impacted me more
than the death of cooper harris this
event
cooper's life is a benchmark that we
should all
look to particularly
when it comes to the most defenseless i
mean the
most vulnerable and defenseless among us
clearly there's a lot to unpack when it
comes to the justin ross harris case
with many aspects just
hard to believe here's the thing though
that may be
the biggest surprise hot car deaths
still happen to this day that's a
problem that needs to stop
now and hopefully it doesn't take cases
like this one
for that to happen that's all we have
for you here on prime crime
leave us your comments on instagram and
twitter with the hashtag primecrime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you